[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hello, hello.
It's good to be with you.
Hello, everyone.
Greetings, especially, to
my comrades at Radcliffe.
There are 45 of
us, give or take,
from every hill and molehill
of this intellectual farm.
I'm grateful to my comrades.
We're like a village
here, and it's
good to be among other
farmers in the field
of a mind on whom
we can depend, one
on the other for reassurance,
and sometimes fertilizer.
Now the year is ending.
And the crops are high.
And it's time to bring them in.
Much gratitude to Radcliffe,
Dean, Associate Dean,
and staff, for making us feel
supported and welcome here.
We're made to feel important
beyond the evidence
of our actual contribution
to the common good.
Now my mother had a
soft view of the subject
I want to talk about today.
She said, "he was the one
with the beautiful name."
Constant LeCorgne,
Polycarp Constant LeCorgne,
he used his middle name
because he disliked his first.
When I was a boy, I lived for
a lot of years in Louisiana,
down south in New Orleans.
That's the home of
my mother's family.
My mother's people have
lived in New Orleans
for about 200 years.
My father's family are all from
Charleston, South Carolina,
on the other side
of the southeast
where they've lived
for about 300 years.
I lived with my
family in Charleston
for part of my childhood.
And then something happened,
and that was my father died.
And so my mother picked us up--
I have one brother,
we were young,
I wasn't even a teenager-- and
moved us over to New Orleans.
She wanted to be
close to her people
because she was alone
and thought to look
for help raising her boys.
My mother's family
in New Orleans
have been and remain
plain people--
clerks, tradesmen, school
teachers, salesmen, carpenters,
nurses, nobody at all with a
higher education for 150 years
until the 1970s.
So when we arrived, we
moved in with my grandmother
into her bungalow,
which was raised up
against the floods that
plagued New Orleans.
This is my mother on the left.
That's me sitting on her
lap in the mid 1960s.
And in the back is my mother's
mother, Edna LeCorgne.
Living with my
grandmother, also,
was a woman named Maude,
my grandmother's sister,
Maude LeCorgne.
And it was with Aunt
Maude that I first
learned about the Klansmen.
Aunt Maude was about 75
when I first paid attention.
She was a school teacher.
And she was unmarried,
never married,
what used to be
called a spinster.
She wore wire-rimmed glasses.
She wore her long white hair,
usually, coiled up in a bun
tight against the
back of her head.
She had a closet full
of gingham dresses.
She wore opaque
stockings with the seam
down the back of the calf.
She wore heavy black shoes with
a clunky two-inch square heel
that clattered on the
floor of the bungalow.
She had pursed lips.
"Come here, boy, let me
tell you about our people."
"Aunt Maude, can I
have a Coca-Cola?"
Aunt Maude was the
family historian.
Now in every family,
especially in the South,
there is a keeper of lore.
She's usually a woman.
She's usually not married,
either made single
by divorce, or death,
or never married.
She gathers in the
stories of all those
who are no longer with us.
She makes family trees.
She pretends to be a writer.
Aunt Maude was that person.
"Yes, surely you can
have a Coca-Cola.
Here, let me tell you about
our people, the LeCorgnes.
The first one of us to
arrive here in New Orleans
was Yve LeCorgne, came
from Brittany on the west
coast of France.
He was a sailor in
Napoleon's navy.
And Napoleon, as you may know,
as you will learn in school one
day, was involved in war
from one end of the world
to the other.
And there was an uprising
here at Saint-Domingue.
That's that place--
they now call it Haiti.
And Napoleon sent a
flotilla of warships.
And Yve was on one of them.
And those ships arrived
in the Caribbean.
And for some reason, one of the
ships came up to New Orleans.
Yve got off the ship
and never got back on.
Well Yve was about 28--
are you listening boy--
when he arrived in New Orleans.
And he found a wife,
19-year-old woman
named Marguerite Zeringue.
The Zeringues were a
prosperous sugar planting
family from Bayou Lafourche.
But they weren't
that prosperous.
And they were somewhat
in decline, slow decline.
So they consented,
or condescended,
to allow Marguerite to
marry Yve who'd washed up.
And when they did marry, they
moved into that little creole
cottage on Dauphine Street,
down in the French Quarter.
Now they didn't call it the
French Quarter at that time,
you know.
It was this, merely,
le Vieux Carre.
It was the Old Quarter.
It was where all the
French people lived.
And these people were French.
Everybody's speaking French
in the LeCorgne household.
We were French, you see.
And despite the fact that the
Americans had bought Louisiana,
we did not stop speaking French.
We remained French
for another century.
So they had their
five children there.
And among them was
my grandfather,
Constant LeCorgne,
Constant LeCorgne.
He was a Redeemer.
Do you know about
the Redemption?"
"No, ma'am.
Can I have another Coca-Cola?"
"The Redemption, that
was after the Civil War,
when the colored people
had taken over the state.
They started businesses.
They were acting as though
everything was theirs.
They were voting.
The Redemption was after that
time they call Reconstruction,
that awful time.
Now Reconstruction
was not when the South
tried to build itself
up again after the war
between the states.
It was not when the
houses were rebuilt
after the Yankees burned them.
No, Reconstruction was when
they put colored people
in the seat of power.
The Redemption was the time
when people resisted that.
And so my grandfather,
Constant, he was a Redeemer.
He wanted to restore white rule.
And he got tied up
that White League."
"Aunt Maude, what is
The White League?"
"The White League-- the only
difference between The White
League and the Ku Klux is that
the Ku Klux were secretive.
What the Ku Klux liked
to do in secret at night,
The White League did out
in the open during the day.
And thank God for
The White League
because they put the Negro
out of the seat of power.
Can you imagine the Negro
with authority here?"
And so it was from Aunt
Maude, the spinster
and family historian
that I first
learned about our Klansman.
I grew up.
I put the story of
the Redemption away.
I went to college,
finished, ended up
with a path in journalism.
And then I started
writing books.
30 years passed
and I find myself
in possession of Aunt
Maude's notebooks.
She has died and I've inherited
them, her family trees,
her marriage licenses, and
her death records, and wills,
and stories written down about
the LeCorgnes and their people.
I put them away.
I don't look at them because
I'm afraid they contain
toxic tales of the Ku Klux.
Then comes the day
a few years ago
when Trayvon Martin, a
17-year-old kid in Seminole
County, Florida, was
ambushed and shot
by a vigilante named
George Zimmerman.
And this shakes me.
And I think of the Redeemer.
Then comes the day when
Michael Brown, the 18-year-old
in Ferguson, Missouri, is
shot dead in the street
by the police, an event that
reverberates for a year.
Then comes the day when Tamir
Rice, the 12-year-old boy
in Cleveland, Ohio, was
shot dead in a playground
under a jungle
gym by the police.
And finally comes the day
when a white supremacist
named Dylann Roof, in
Charleston, South Carolina,
walks into a church,
Emmanuel AME Church,
and into a prayer
meeting where people
are discussing the parable
of the sower from Mark.
So, "as ye sow,
so shall ye reap."
And he shoots nine people dead.
So I open Aunt Maude's files.
And I decide to look
for the Klansman, which
is, at this point, merely
a slice of oral tradition.
When I start, it is a story that
is unburdened by much research.
But today, having
spent 18 months
in and out of the
archives, I have
a sense of the paper trail.
The story I'm developing, here
at Harvard, is a family memoir.
But it is not the
sentimental, gauzy kind.
Polycarp Constant LeCorgne,
a person long dead,
his life a quilt of family
lore and public records,
was a man white
Southerners once cheered
as a savior along with
thousands of other Redeemers
in the first generation
of the Ku Klux.
He was a tradesman and
father of five who became,
in a way, a founding father
when he took up with Klan groups
in Louisiana.
LeCorgne's life
and choices helped
to cement white over black
during a time, Reconstruction,
when white domination
was under threat.
After the Klan won
the race battles
of the post Civil War South
and the Jim Crow caste system
was locked down, everyone
knew that restoring whiteness
to power, following
its years of retreat,
was the movement's
lasting achievement.
And perhaps, this marginal
man touches the fingertips
of current politics.
Perhaps his life makes
visible the class resentments,
the desire for ethnic
purity, and the free floating
fear that underlie
extremes of whiteness.
It may be possible
to argue that some
of the hostility of white
identity in the present
can be traced to sources in
the first years of the Ku Klux.
An aggressive form of
whiteness has been resurgent.
It moved into the open when the
Ku Klux Klan and race speech
streamed into the 2016 election.
It surfaces naked
racism with the naming
of the alt-right movement
and crested, perhaps,
in the white-lash
that helped to sweep
a new president into office.
I am trying to recount the birth
hours of white supremacy using
the experience of
a guerrilla fighter
who battled it into the world.
I am trying to decide whether
more than 100 years ago, one
man and his gangs lit
fires that still burn.
The Ku Klux Klan arose
throughout the South in 1867,
soon after the Civil War.
But in Louisiana, the
Klan used other names,
the Knights of the
White Camellia,
The White League, The Innocents.
Constant LeCorgne fought
with the Knights of the White
Camellia and The White League.
The Ku Klux Klan
and their comrades
are the bogeyman of
American history,
everyone's first choice for
evil, ignorance, and hatred.
But as with other villains,
people know them through image
and legend, the torch light
rallies of hooded men--
shorthand for
Southern depravity--
supply the imagery.
The 1915 D. W. Griffith
film about the Klan,
Birth of a Nation,
provides the black legend.
I want to name what
the Klan originally
did through one man
that actually did it--
the street battles, and night
riding, the banquet of violence
that made people like my
great-great-grandfather
infamous in his own lifetime.
Early Klansmen, like Constant
LeCorgne, were, in their way,
the original authors
of extreme whiteness.
They did not write
its theory, which
grew up within universities
during LeCorgne's lifetime
as scientific racism.
Instead, the Ku Klux
devised its practice,
intimidation of non-whites,
menacing gang rallies,
exclusive claims to economic
and political spoils,
and targeted violence.
In the aftermath of
the November elections,
it is possible to see
the white vote that
flooded to the
Republicans, not only
as an expression of working
class insecurity, but also
as a clamoring for
a kind of whiteness.
And during the first months
of a new administration,
it is possible to see
politics that are remotely,
but persuasively, moved
by feelings of entitlement
that find harmony
with some of the deeds
I'm about to describe.
Constant LeCorgne
was born in 1832
to a French family
in New Orleans.
He is the second of three sons.
His parents give his older
brother the education,
and Constant goes into a trade.
He grows up a small, thin
man, nervous and alert,
sharp features, skinny nose,
beautiful hands, an underbite,
and a furrowed brow, a
long wave of dark hair,
which turned white early.
As a cistern maker, he
built the wooden casks
that stood in the yards of
most houses in New Orleans
where they held drinking water.
At 24, in 1856, Constant marries
Gabrielle Duchemin, age 19,
an orphan of French descent
from the Caribbean island
of Martinique.
In 1860, as the
Civil War approaches,
Constant is a carpenter
living in a rented
house with his wife, Gabrielle,
and their two children
in this neighborhood, at the
time a suburb of New Orleans,
called Bouligny.
His parents are dead.
His mother, during
her last years,
had sold her rice
farm and its people--
she was a slave holder with
eight enslaved people--
and divided the proceeds
among her children.
Constant and Gabrielle
received $500
and two enslaved people,
35-year-old Ovide
and 24-year-old Polly.
In 1861, just before the
first shots of the Civil War,
the couple sells Ovide like
real estate for $1,000.
They knew Louisiana would fight.
And they wanted to
liquidate their biggest
asset in case
slaves became free,
robbing them of their windfall.
They would not
move quickly enough
to sell Polly, who would,
indeed, soon become free.
At the start of the
war of secession,
Constant enlists in
a Confederate company
and heads for Virginia.
But the unit falls
apart in a mutiny.
And he deserts and makes
his way home to Louisiana.
When Union forces stream up
the Mississippi and occupy New
Orleans, he flees,
again, leaving
Gabrielle and the children.
"He walked north up
the Mississippi levee
some 50 miles," said my
aunt, Maude LeCorgne.
When he reached
Confederate lines,
he joined another unit, the
14th Trans Mississippi Regiment,
and fought for the
rest of the war.
In summer 1865, after the
truce, after the assassination
of Lincoln, he comes home to
New Orleans sick, exhausted,
and bitter.
He arrived in a city
"full of carpetbaggers
and with the Negroes
twice as numerous."
Now with three children, he
found his livelihood wrecked.
Louisiana was occupied
by the US Army.
New Orleans was crowded
with black freed people.
And Yankees and
thieves ran everything.
He felt himself a victim, saw
the new order as anathema,
and descended into resentment.
The government was pro-Negro
and colored people actually
held office, a bona
fide perversion.
"Imagine a Negro in the White
House," said Aunt Maude.
This is a guide to New Orleans
published during this time,
called Zachary's Guide.
Reconstruction came.
Reconstruction was the
name of the first attempt
to remake the US as a
racially mixed democracy.
To some, not least to
four million ex-slaves,
it meant power sharing with
whites, possibly even wealth
sharing, and somewhere in the
distance, shared humanity.
These fantastical ideas,
called Radical Reconstruction
by their millions
of white opponents,
met mass obstruction and
popular violence defiance.
Constant took the
extreme step and joined
the armed resistance.
He became a
guerrilla fighter who
wanted to return the
South to white rule.
He became a Klansman,
one of the foot soldiers,
not a Grand Dragon or a Hydra,
to use titles from the first Ku
Klux precepts.
The Ku Klux movement
started in Tennessee in 1866
as a former Confederate
general named Nathan Bedford
Forrest led the initial
night raids and terror
strikes against black
people and against whites
who supported Reconstruction.
The tactics of these
gangs spread quickly.
And by 1867, Klan
raiders were operating
in most counties of the south.
The name Ku Klux derives from
the Greek, kyklos, or circle,
and gangs as everyone
knows sometimes dressed
in costume and mask.
Klansman made a
cult of disguise,
wearing robes and hoods
to avoid identification
by the Army occupiers.
Klansman also knew their
victims personally and preferred
to torment them anonymously.
The first major explosion in New
Orleans occurred in July 1866.
And circumstantial evidence
puts Constant LeCorgne there.
At the Mechanics Institute,
a meeting hall for tradesman,
during a convention to
agitate for the black vote,
an assault of Klan rage
leaves 40 black people dead,
perhaps many more.
An early disguise of
the White Brigades
was the costume of fireman.
Volunteer fire companies
were overstaffed, and armed,
and made up of entire
Confederate companies.
Constant's was Home
Hook and Ladder,
made up of his former Company
C in the 14th Regiment.
Home Hook and Ladder
was on the scene
to break up the meeting
about the black vote
and then the shooting started.
During the next
eight years, evidence
shows LeCorgne and perhaps
2,000 others in the state,
raided, marched,
and beat people.
Some gangs assassinated
black leaders.
There was night riding,
whippings, and ambush killings.
According to court records,
an attempted Klan coup
is among the incidents in which
my great-great-grandfather
found his claim to glory.
In March, 1873,
after an election,
LeCorgne joined a putsch
against the state government.
At home that night before
leaving for the action,
he said goodbye to his wife,
Gabrielle, and their four
children, all younger than
12, because he did not
expect to return.
In the night time attack,
LeCorgne and an armed gang
of 20 surrounded a police depot
in New Orleans and shot it up,
seized the building.
Theirs was one fork of
a two-pronged mission.
A second group stormed
the city's main armory
but failed to overcome it.
LeCorgne's gang
held its position.
And the standoff ensued for
days with the military camped
nearby.
If the plan could bring down
the Louisiana government, even
for a week, then the US
Army, which shored up
the new and precarious civil
rights laws could be forced
to withdraw from the state and
white rule might be taken back.
The army stormed the
building and two were killed.
LeCorgne and the
others were charged
with treason and with
violating the Ku Klux Klan Act.
In Washington,
Congress had hoped
it's 1871 Klan Act
would stamp out
the white gangs in the South.
The Klan penalty was five years.
The treason penalty was hanging.
LeCorgne was not the
only one in the family
who fought for white rule.
His brother-in-law,
his nephew, and several
of his French cousins played
greater or lesser roles.
In the treason case,
the gallows were
being discussed when a
sympathetic white judge
dismissed all counts, freeing
LeCorgne and his conspirators.
He returned to the
street and to the fight.
Before the Klan coup, he had
belonged to a different group,
the so-called
Knights of the White
Camellia led by a family friend
named Alcibiades DeBlanc.
The aim of the Knights
was to reverse black gains
since Emancipation by
any means necessary.
Between 1867 and 1869, their
attacks left 1,750 people dead
or wounded in Louisiana,
90% of them black.
The Knights also
generated racist dogma.
LeCorgne and other
men who joined
the Knights went
through an initiation
held by torchlight
at night where
they voiced a supremacist oath.
This is a newspaper in
the Houghton Library,
which has some interesting
things pertinent to this story.
The oath, "I am attached
to the Order of the Knights
of the White Camellia.
The Order grows on the
mountain known as Caucasus.
I do solemnly swear
to maintain and defend
the social and
political superiority
of the white race
on this continent,
always and in all places to
observe a marked distinction
between the white
and African races,
and to protect
and defend persons
of the white race in their
lives, rights, and property
against the encroachments
and aggressions
of an inferior race."
This kind of language, taken
from one of the earliest Klan
creeds, allows one to
trace a chain of ideas
that reaches from 150 years
ago and stretches down
through the generations.
It is a genealogy that wraps
around one Klansman's life
and spools out, forming
a dotted and irregular
line that runs to the present.
Are the activities
of The White League
and the Knights of the White
Camellia relevant today?
It may be possible.
These were murderous militias.
But occasionally, they
generated statements of purpose
in which they called for
a strong and dominant
white racial identity.
During the past
year, we have heard
on the lips of a
few in public life
the explicit desire for an
ethno-state, a country made
safe for the majority.
And we have heard
the coded speech
of some who would have us
make America white again.
The Knights of the White
Camellia as well as
its successor, The White
League, LeCorgne's third gang,
saw themselves as
freedom fighters
on the side of justice.
In 1874, LeCorgne and 2,000
white league fighters--
they had swelled from a fugitive
minority into a mass brigade--
staged another coup,
this time successful.
On September 14, in
the so-called battle
of Canal Street, the Ku Klux
toppled the interracial state
government.
LeCorgne was badly
wounded in the clash.
He had his head split open,
says family tradition.
But The White League held
Louisiana's capital building
for a week.
Though the army
again took power,
the Klansmen knew they
had lost this battle
and yet won the war.
US troops soon
withdrew from Louisiana
and from the rest of the South.
And by 1876, a white
monopoly was again
taking shape in the region.
It was the beginning of
100 years of Jim Crow,
the system of color caste.
Constant LeCorgne died
in 1886 of malaria.
He left sons who
became carpenters
like their father, daughters
who mothered or taught school.
He left grandchildren,
including my grandmother, Edna,
and her sister, Maude, proud
daughters of tradition.
Six years after his death,
not far from the family house,
a colored man named Homer
Plessy boarded a white train
car in a staged act
of civil disobedience.
Plessy and a group
of activists wanted
to challenge the
barriers of segregation.
He was arrested.
And the Supreme Court decision
in Plessy versus Ferguson
drew the bright line
of separate but equal
between white and
non-white, setting in law
the stratification that LeCorgne
had fought in the street
to establish.
After the Plessy
case, black people
were not entitled to
most public space,
nor most education,
nor most housing.
Simultaneously, a
surge of vagrancy laws
and the development
of convict leasing--
a slave like prison system--
produced the first wave
of black mass incarceration.
Jail enforced work became
a normal experience
for black men.
Race strata were refined into
clear social and psychological
planes with whiteness,
the Brahmin standard.
Since then, the redemption
of white rule has weakened.
This is a Klan march
in Washington, DC
in the mid 1920s.
But it has a way of
prolonging itself.
A tilt toward blackness and
brownness in the race dialectic
tends to be followed
by a white backlash.
Backlash.
Then gives way
incrementally only
to yield eventually to
another success for whiteness.
There is Attorney General
Jefferson Beauregard Sessions
in the front--
I'm kidding here.
He's--
[LAUGHTER]
- President Barack Obama
often quoted a phrase
used by Martin Luther King,
"the arc of the moral universe
is long, but it bends
towards justice."
Why retrieve from obscurity this
bitter and bloody Klan story?
There is a personal motive,
and that is that it bothers me.
It feels like finding a
corpse in the bedroom.
I'm disgusted and ashamed.
I had an inkling that
a great-grandfather
had been a violent supremacist.
But I did not see until research
just what he'd gotten up to.
He was not a thoughtful man.
He could write an invoice
for his carpentry work.
But that's about all.
And he did not develop the
idea of white entitlement
that still circulates like an
odorless gas in the duct work.
But God knows he put
poison in that gas.
And he damaged the
lives of hundreds.
But for other people
and not for me,
why revive this filthy
story and bring it back?
One reason is to try to harness
the tale of Constant LeCorgne,
to repurpose it in some hope of
shining a small light on steps
forward.
50 years after the end of
the Civil Rights Movement,
the white and black divide
remains caustic and fresh.
That is because the US possesses
a tragic history, some of which
Americans are unaware
of because much of it
lies in the repressed
parts of collective memory.
White supremacy of
all kinds, especially,
is willfully forgotten.
Here is another metaphor.
Tribal whiteness is
like an infection
trapped within a closed wound.
To tell a story of a Klansman
is to cut into the wound
and to wash it out in the
hope that it heals again
with better result.
One reason to summon
these harsh events
is to apply a dose
of storytelling
to the injuries inflicted
by supremacy, by extremist
whiteness.
The medicine comes late.
And it is inadequate
to the wound.
But we know that is needed.
What are some of the
legacies of this Klansman
and his Reconstruction
race wars?
Here is one.
Many whites find it
uncomfortable to speak
about whiteness.
We disliked being
labeled a member
of a race, dislike acknowledging
that race is power.
That is partly because
the Ku Klux and people
like Constant LeCorgne made
whiteness an invisible norm.
Supremacy is natural.
And it was made so in part
by events in this story.
The deep legacy
of the Ku Klux is
the idea of whiteness,
itself, which many of us
can hardly perceive.
This is a monument to The White
League in New Orleans, which
stood at the center of
the city for 125 years
and was removed last week
under the cover of night
with city workers wearing ski
masks with snipers on the roof
tops of buildings
around it at 3:00 AM
because city was worried that
there would be a reaction.
The deep legacy
of the Ku Klux is
the idea of whiteness, which
many of us can hardly perceive.
I look hard to see it.
The outline comes
into focus slowly,
like sitting in a dark room and
waiting for the eyes to adjust.
Whiteness is not just personal.
It is not just a matter
of microaggressions.
Whiteness, semi-consciously,
puts its hands
on the levers of
politics and power,
which brings us to
the White House.
It is November 2016.
150 years after the raids and
the victory of the Redemption,
a conference takes place at
the Harvard Kennedy School.
It brings together
the campaign managers
for all of the
presidential campaigns--
13, I think, Republican
campaigns, and the Clinton
campaign, and the
Sanders campaign.
I attended this conference as
a guest of a faculty member
there.
And in a room this
size, 200 people
are arrayed around a
rectangular table in the center.
And all of the campaign managers
are seated at this table.
It's two weeks
after the election.
And they're telling war stories.
There's a guy there named Paul
Manafort, whom you may know
was a manager of the
Donald Trump campaign
until about April 2016,
when he was run off
the campaign for malfeasance.
There was a guy there named
Corey Lewandowski, whom
you may remember was
the subsequent manager
of the Donald Trump campaign
until he was run off
of the campaign for malfeasance.
There was a woman there
named Kellyanne Conway,
who was the last man standing
when the election actually
happened and who's now
a White House adviser.
And Cory Lewandowski
is saying, "we
wanted to make sure we got
the populous message across.
And the way we did that
was to show the money.
We made sure that the
airplane was in every TV shot.
We made sure we had the most
expensive hotels, the most
expensive cars.
And we made every
interview on the plane.
We wanted to show
that what we had
was one of the very most
successful and richest men
in the country because we knew
that that was the way to reach
the great mass of the people.
That's what they wanted."
So there was a day of this
kind of gloating war stories
until the end of the day
when the conference blew up
and there was a disagreement
between the Clinton
people and the Trump people.
And here is an excerpt five
minutes long from that.
- [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, we can go
through the list.
But it's not as though
there weren't moments
in the campaign where
he created controversy
having to do with race,
or gender, or religion.
- But Dan, can we--
- But how does that affect--
your question was
about Steve Bannon.
- Well, because he was--
- You're trying to
dovetail the two things.
So when Donald Trump said
something in January, February,
March, April, whenever--
had nothing to do with the
smear campaign of the left
on Steve Bannon today.
OK.
Well it's ridiculous.
And to be candid
with you, the guy
is an unbelievably
brilliant strategist
who is really a terrific guy
who, as Kellyanne just said,
a guy who has a
Harvard pedigree and is
getting attacked by people who
have no idea how many years--
- Wait.
Hold on, OK.
No.
- We happen to sitting here.
But listen.
He gets held to a standard
that none of these other folks
will be held to.
- Let me--
- Dan, if providing a platform
for white supremacists
makes me a brilliant tactician,
I am glad to have lost.
And one of Hillary--
give me a minute, David.
I am more proud of Hillary
Clinton's alt-right speech than
any other moment on the campaign
because she had the courage
to stand up--
I would rather lose than
win the way you guys did.
- No, you wouldn't.
- Yes.
- Absolutely.
- Yes, yes.
- That's very clear today.
No, you wouldn't, respectfully.
I'm sorry, how
exactly did we win?
No, go for it, Jen.
How exactly did we win?
I'd like to know.
Because I sacrificed the last
four months of my life to do--
excuse me--
and we did it.
And we did it by
looking at the schedule
and looking at, yes, the
electoral map of 270.
Because that's how you
win the presidency.
And we went places.
And we were either
ignored or mocked roundly
by most of the
people in this room.
But I have a smile on
my face at all times.
And we did it by focusing with
Steve Bannon and Dave Bossie
and everybody you see here.
They're going to
say, "oh, she just
said Corey was part of the
campaign," Jeff Zucker.
OK, Corey, until whatever.
What was that June?
And we focused on
how you would-- we
connected with voters.
We connected with voters.
- --hiring is himself.
We've already gone through
some of the examples
of his own language, his
own positions that I believe
are at odds with my
values as an American
of embracing diversity,
inclusivity, equality,
and hiring someone
like Steve Bannon--
- --which is exactly
what Breitbart--
- --who with Breitbart--
- --if you guys you spend a
few minutes on Breitbart--
- --gives these
people a platform.
- You say things
doesn't make it true.
- One of my proudest
moments of her,
is her standing up and saying
with courage and clarity,
in Steve Bannon's own words
and Donald Trump's own words,
the platform that they
gave to white supremacists,
white nationalists--
and it's a very,
very important moment in
our history of our country.
And I think as his
presidency goes forward,
I'm going to be very
glad to have been part
of the campaign that's tried--
- Jen, do you think-- excuse
me, she said white supremacy.
- Well, I would actually--
- I'm sorry.
I know it's mentioned a
lot on your website too.
Do you think I ran a campaign
where white supremacists had
a platform?
You going to look me in
the face and tell me that?
- It's did.
Kellyanne, it did.
- And that's how you lost.
Do you think you could have
just had a decent message--
- You guys are pathetic.
- --for the white
working-class voters.
You think this woman
who has nothing
in common with anybody--
- I'm not saying that's
how you won, but that's--
- [INAUDIBLE] over 200 counties
that President Obama won
and Donald Trump just won.
You think that's because
of what you just said
or because people aren't
ready for a woman president.
Really?
How about it's Hillary Clinton?
She doesn't connect with people.
How about they have
nothing in common with her?
How about you had
no economic message?
- Guys
- --honest conversation
about what happened in this
campaign--
- We are.
- --so hold on.
- You guys are not.
- They want this to be
about the strategists.
That's right.
- You guys are punching down.
It's unbelievable.
- Hold on.
You're talking about
one Steve Bannon.
[GROANING]
- There's another Steve Bannon,
as the CEO of Breitbart.
He, himself, has said that was
a platform for the alt-right,
the platform.
Now just two weeks ago--
in the rise of the
at-right, which
is now part of the
mainstream of our politics,
America is for white people.
So don't tell me.
And that is the
kind of platform--
there's a video of it.
That is the--
- No, no, no.
Prove yourself of what
you just said, Karen.
Prove yourself.
I have the idea that there
is white supremacy on the one
hand.
And there is white
supremacy on the other.
There's violent
supremacy and yet,
all the way across the spectrum,
there's a kinder, gentler kind.
It is Father's Knows
Best whiteness.
It is atmospheric.
And it permeates
the social common.
I have the idea
that supremacy is
a gas introduced in pure form
by the people I've talked about.
And yet the chemical is
titrated and diluted in order
to circulate invisibly.
Now I don't think that we
are in the midst of a return
to the barbarism of the
race wars of the Old South
during Reconstruction.
In my worldview, perhaps that
is what passes for optimism.
Although within the
last weeks, there
have been street
fights involving
supremacist at Berkeley.
There is little doubt,
however, that the concentration
of that gas in
the air is rising.
And we are in a period of rising
white anger in its ugly forms.
I leave you with what
my Aunt Maude said
to me, which was,
"son, we are part
of the petit blanc, the petit
blanc, the little whites.
That's what they callled us.
Le grand blanc called us that.
And the Negroes called
us that, the petit blanc.
We are not grand
people, but small ones.
And my grandfather, he
was trying to lift us up.
It is too bad with
that White League.
But they ain't nothing we can
do about it now, now is there?"
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]